der mann hinter mir denn nennt sich
campus lies und ist ein gangster rapper
und auch wenn sie wahrscheinlich noch
nie von ihm gehört haben seine lieder
die wurden auf youtube
123 millionen mal geklickt und zwar na
klar vor allem von jugendlichen und
genau das macht die verbrechen die der
rapper selbst begangen haben soll noch
unerträglicher campus eis ist wegen
zuhälterei vergewaltigung
zwangsprostitution und sexuellen
missbrauch von jugendlichen angeklagt
sein jüngstes opfer soll gerade einmal
15 jahre alt gewesen sein juni von der
osten und benjamin sack berichten
die sorgt du kannst mir geld führt ihn
seine zu den männern muss schon
bestellen sie viel doch es blieb nicht
nur bei einer bestellung rote sturms
renten und dafür steht gangsta-rapper
campus lies heute vor gericht 39
dienstagmorgen leichtfüßig kommt der
horror rapper in den verhandlungsraum
doch die anklage wiegt schwer seit
letzter woche steht er in düsseldorf vor
dem landgericht ihm wird in mindestens
16 fällen zwangsprostitution an sechs
frauen vorgeworfen zum einen soll auch
eine der frauen mit einer pistole an der
schläfe zum oralsex gezwungen haben
weitere vorwürfe der 37-seitigen
anklageschrift
drogenhandel beleidigung und
misshandlung alles im zusammenhang mit
der körperlichen ausbeutung junger
frauen
polierten überwacht haben und auf
gehandelt haben eine geschädigte solle
entscheidungs mitteln abhängig gemacht
haben und ihren angeboten haben die
drohungen aus den einnahmen der
prostitution zu bezahlen
rambus lies 32 jahre alt gangsta rapper
und schwerverbrecher in seinen
musikvideos trotz der mit schnellen
autos drogen und frauen mehr als 50.000
personen folgen dem türkischstämmigen
rebroff instagram zehn millionen mal
werden seine musikvideos geklickt mit
seiner musik will come bus lies den
deutschen rap olymp erklimmen doch diese
karriere scheint in horror rapper nicht
genug er soll vizepräsident eines
rockerclubs gewesen sein immer wieder
bricht campus leistungsgesetze nach
eigenen angaben saß der gangster rapper
bereits fünf jahre im gefängnis
13 monate davon in isolationshaft unter
seinem linken auge trägt der horror
rapper stolz eine kalaschnikow tätowiert
damit sie ihn an krieg gewalt und blut
erinnert aus seiner verachtung für
frauen macht der horror rapper keinen
hehl dann schaute so viele frauen in
mein leben und das waren so viele
verlogene schlanken in seinen
musikvideos erniedrigt campus lies
frauen zu objekten nancy bush und co
also [ __ ] und muss
[Musik]
doch campus lies frauenverachtung geht
noch weiter in den jahren 2018 und 2021
soll er brutale straftaten gegenüber
frauen begangen haben zuhälterei
vergewaltigung zwangsprostitution und
sexueller missbrauch von jugendlichen in
einem apartment komplex soll der
32-jährige gangsta-rapper zimmer
angemietet haben wo die frauen sich
prostituieren haben müssen des weiteren
hatte er auch noch zimmer in köln in
einem hotel angemietet oder in einer
ferienwohnung in braunschweig mit der
sogenannten loverboy masche soll der
rapper die jungen mädchen hindu
prostitution gezwungen haben wenn sie
nicht gehorchen
sein jüngstes opfer gerade einmal 15
jahre alt
die loverboy masche ein besonders
perfider trick junge mädchen in die
prostitution zu zwingen bei dieser
methode beiden jahr weibliche
minderjährige und junge frauen meistens
unter der vorspiegelung einer
liebesbeziehung in ein emotionales
abhängigkeitsverhältnis mitmachen und
sie dann später der prostitution
zurückzuführen und aus geburten
im jahr 2019 werden laut angaben des bka
81 frauen opfer der loverboy masche doch
die experten schätzen die dunkelziffer
deutlich höher aus scham zeigen viele
frauen die emotionale und körperliche
ausbeutung ihrer peiniger nicht an
insbesondere durch social media ist es
für die täter einfacher geworden zugang
zu ihrem potenziellen opfer zu bekommen
suchen sie zum beispiel auch in social
media über die einzelnen profile von
jungen frauen und mädchen ob sie dort
angeben aktuelle probleme in der schule
zu haben oder in der familie
und so finden die täter später quasi
auch angriffspunkte um erstmal in eine
unterhaltung mit den jungen frauen
einzusteigen in dem land unterstützung
und fußbruch erfolgt und eben auch die
gewünschte aufmerksamkeit die diese
jungen frauen gerade brauchen auch
bekommen
wir wollen wissen was männer zu solchen
taten antreibt und treffen psychologin
maler sein sie ist expertin in der
analyse von labor und deren psyche es
geht nicht um diese junge frau konkret
persönlich als mensch sondern sie ist
einfach ein objekt das man
wirtschaftlich ausbeuten kann weil aber
es zeichnen sich immer wiederkehrende
charaktereigenschaften hat eine
gefährliche mischung aus narzissmus und
charisma
häufig ist es eben so dass ausgeprägt
psychopathische eigenschaften bei diesen
labors vorhanden sind dass es sind sehr
akustisch sie haben diesen
oberflächlichen charme sie haben diese
exzellenten manipulations fähigkeiten
sie beherrschen dieses spiel mit
zuckerbrot und peitsche
vor gericht leugnete der horror rapper
die vorwürfe die jungen mädchen hätten
sich bei ihm gemeldet und wollten
freiwillig für campus live anschaffen
gehen tatsächlich ist es so dass wohl
eine dame 50 gewesen eine 17 das hatte
allerdings nicht gewusst dann die von
dem äußeren erscheinungsbild durchaus
den eindruck von älteren damen
vermittelt haben sondern das waren
mitunter damen die das schon vorher
betrieben haben die auf ihn zugekommen
sind ja weil sie halt im hintergrund
kanten dass er durchaus diesem
background hatte und dann noch die
zusammenarbeit im team wollen aber alles
einfach insgesamt sind 17
verhandlungstage bis april angesetzt im
fall einer verurteilung drohen campus
live
gesagt du willst dich mal sportgruppe
ja natürlich bleiben wir an diesem fall
bei kann